gang quick update on the middle class
famous tour we're going to be coming to
the moon tower comedy festival that's
austin baby teja april 22nd and 23rd
april 22nd we're going to be doing an
evening with ru garbage that's our
stand-up show and then we play a little
ayg with the crowd yes best news is it's
open to the public get your tickets
link's gonna be in the description you
get them on the moon tower comedy
festival website find the link get the
tickies then the next night we're doing
a live ru garbage podcast recording with
a guest to be determined it's gonna be
good get your tickets that austin let's
go broncos welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
found it if they grow up to be classy
yeah or if they're just a big old piece
of trash i'm your host dave foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here in aunt toddy's basement she is
unfortunately going to be upstate for a
couple of weeks oh no what happened
she's fishing
okay which is what they call scalping
out uh new prisoners at sinksing cause
that's where she is i don't wanna get
into it she said she wasn't gonna roll
on us when i talked to her on the phone
but then i heard her say to somebody not
on the phone did you get all that so we
could be in a little bit of trouble i
think i like the shorter ones my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
he is the ceo of are you garbage bit of
an international businessman sure he's
my best pal in the whole wide world and
i love them give it up for kj kevin
james ryan love you too buddy uh
that was beautiful by the way yeah i
couldn't even get through that really uh
what's up everybody that's completely
insincere
thanks for tuning in uh please make sure
you rate view subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube as you know
those numbers are true the roof cooking
and i'd like to thank a personal note to
thank sam yam and jack conte for
inventing the greatest website of all
time www.patreon.com
garbage go there sign up we'll let the
boys wet their beaks you get a bunch of
content it's [ __ ] awesome check it
out having a good time how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin toby mcmullen everybody what's
up dudes what's up buttons nothing dude
well this is aaron we're out in
california and i'm getting called a
poser by real dears
getting beat up by teenagers on santa
monica boulevard
you guys do a kickflip what's up this
guy's a cop man gang that's neither here
nor there because we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly special
guest here with us today for the first
time we got a little internet star power
tight little body tell you that right
now good looking kid a very successful
very funny comedian youtuber and
podcaster of course he is the host of
the amazing podcast the basement yard
the co-creator of the board game speak
out he has multiple youtube channels
totaling subscriber base you ready for
this something true to roof i bet 3
million
363
000 subscribers
with hundreds upon hundreds of millions
of views but the big question about his
mind today is he garbage i don't know
about all that but i do know two things
he's got a little bit of cash and the
kid's a [ __ ] looker
right now he is he's [ __ ] he's young
he's hot he's successful he's smart i
don't know what's going on he's got some
jewelry cool tattoos give me your
favorite gang give me a nice big round
of applause for joe santagato everybody
oh thank you guys let him hear it one of
the greatest intros of all time honestly
thank you big man likes an intro
i'm [ __ ] gassed up now three million
i was like i don't even know how many to
put this in your guest stuff i've been
able to think since you walked in the
room
[Laughter]
it'd be great if you had a 3.3 million
what the [ __ ] am i doing here
i'm just trying to think if you got a
t-shirt underneath that sweater i walked
in i was like am i in the right place
i feel like i'm not in the right place
you're here for the union job
buddy thank you so much for coming and
sitting down with us no yeah i'm excited
i i don't know how but i got a dm from
you guys like hey you wanna come on show
us like six months ago and i just like
didn't even finally got back to him he's
like oh yeah i'll do it it's like
awesome let's go i pull that move all
the time yeah the message requests leave
it on scene oh just saw this sorry about
that we got it down
what is the back story joe where are you
from give us the whole scoop queenscape
i grew up in a astoria queen
yeah where the boys live is that where
you're from oh you're you live there now
let me tell you the bed bugs and queens
are top-notch they are also the movie
theater out in there they're famous for
their bed bugs yeah what kaufman yeah
really yeah they were like we got bed
bugs it's like i'm still going to see
i still got to see batman what are we
doing here i'm still going to get jerked
off there i don't care about the bedbugs
it's a good trade-off hey they got to
get a claw machine what do you mean to
tell you uh-huh great claw machine
honestly they do they really do
everybody wins at that one yeah it's
fantastic they have the little duckies
in there you always get one
so you grew up in astoria that's where i
live now been living there for a long
time gentrifying the place oh yeah they
tell you um
give us to give us the scoop uh i mean i
want i mean how how long you been there
uh i've been i lived there
when i lived in new york moved around a
little bit
he's not big with leases that's my drift
here the halfway houses count i don't
know um no bikers is there is that what
you're talking about
that's jack rikers is technically queen
yeah you can't beat the views you know
what i'm saying the whole city no i
lived out there on dipmars when i lived
up here in new york the first time i a
girlfriend of mine was living out there
and i lived here for a little while um
probably 2000 2001 and then when i moved
up here to do comedy uh i've been out
there since what 2016 i would say oh
okay cool yeah that mars was the what
was you know the first place that i felt
like home away from from home and this
was back in the day when it was just k
clitus out there yeah
i was gonna say because when i grew up
there there was just like there was like
a giant hardware store yeah it's like
who's buying all these screws yeah like
you know what's going on but they they
shut them all down recently and now it's
just like there's a bunch of cafes and
whatever yeah it's all popping up it's
popping over there man it's [ __ ]
fantastic yeah like toby said the bed
bugs when you were there in 2001 great
year by the way uh that was when it was
still old and everything was like you
know
they shut them all down though and now
it's just like
there's a bunch of bars there it's
actually a place to to be i remember
probably around 2016 2017 when they
started changing everything
someone had hit me up and was like oh
i'm coming to a story to hang out and i
remember thinking like what the [ __ ]
like there's no deal what's happening
gang fight out here
but now it's nice it's a nice place to
be i live right over there too it was
nice growing up for you though though i
imagine it was quiet it was it was yeah
i didn't i lived like on the ditmar side
but a little further away from the train
so i was like how far down were you
i was like on the border of like where
jackson heights is sort of like i was
like right in the middle for like
getting to the train and getting to
jackson heights is like the same
yeah yeah it's like near the border kids
border kids no good
right now but like anytime they can't
just say exactly where they're from it's
a tough one
the one year we were over it was
considered uh jackson heights did you
grow up in a house an apartment no it
was a house it was a house mom dad
brothers sisters uh mom and dad hated
each other so
classic you know dad's in north carolina
now i haven't seen him in years
he's right on the border though down
there
north and south carolina exactly yeah he
doesn't give you his address i don't
even know if he's in north carolina it
could be in europe by now you know
what's your background
uh what's your family background
what do you what do you mean by that
like
oh yeah we're we're italian polish what
the [ __ ] i know white is going to be
italian irish
but i'm really like i have no cultural
anything yeah right
yeah you know they're not wearing the
horn yeah no and there was never like a
pair of like italian boxing gloves
no picture of the pope hanging up in the
kitchen no one in my family has like a
cross with a praying hand sure the brain
hands around
when did your parents split
uh
i don't know when you were a kid yeah i
was probably like 15 16 or something
okay all right and brothers and sisters
yeah i have three i have two brothers
and one sister okay i have three
siblings they're all older than i am oh
you're the youngest baby it's nice the
attention seeker yeah of course buddy
everybody everybody
uh what did your parents do growing up
what did mom and dad do uh my dad was a
fireman
nice new york real new york guy i think
and i mean he also had like a
construction company i'm not really
doing myself any favors
he did roofing on his side
he had his own construction company and
he was a fireman and moonlighted as a
bouncer
but he uh yeah so he was a fireman and
he had that also and then my mom when we
were old enough she went back to school
and then she worked as a secretary she
actually just retired last year yeah
very nice good for her he's living it up
right now and you really you don't have
much of a relationship with your pop
from no i mean i do i would not i like
joke around but like he he moved to to
maryland for a little bit and then he
went to north carolina but i was just on
the phone with him earlier like we still
have like a good relationship but
like he like i said he's in north
carolina i just don't see him very well
but your mom for all intensive purposes
she raised you
yeah i mean they both raised me i mean
like they they my dad stopped living
with us when i was like 16 years old and
like i'm you know i'm being dramatic
about it but they uh
yeah my mom was always around she still
lives in the same house that we grew up
in really yeah what grocery shortage
should go to out there there was [ __ ]
wall bounds for a little bit whoa
and then now it's like some russian [ __ ]
or or uh
it's called where ukraine or team
ukraine that right
take that commie [ __ ] elsewhere say it
it's like lethal ladle what is that
oh oh no it's german
i know exactly what you're talking about
german russian is there really a
difference that's how queens is student
i can't pronounce it it's commie
[ __ ]
you're talking about acme yeah that's
the one that's the guy pieces of [ __ ]
that's a very that's a very neat yeah
that's the guy that's the guy liddell i
think it's called there's something
legal yeah i think it's legal
i think that is right it is whack i
can't remember what that was that was
best market out there you're talking
about the one in the shopping center
yeah it's like it's from the 80s my mom
loved best market hates this [ __ ] and
i don't know if it's because of you know
russia
or whatever it is it's not for your
pearl harbor it's like it's not the same
yes
she's like it's not the same i'm
fighting a proxy war out there in queens
it's not because we used to drive over
there and and do our grocery shopping
there and it was real small town real
nice yeah the [ __ ] deli counter was
nice the kid that did the salmon knew
what he was doing now you walk in there
it's like you're in an ikea yeah and
everything's not everything's trying to
put together your own bananas and [ __ ]
they gave me the wrong pieces
i got an allen wrench for a sandwich
what are we doing here
no everything's like uh
it's frosted flakes but it's not frosted
yeah i hate that [ __ ] it's like frosted
corn something it's weird it's like tony
the aardvark it's like what's going on
here i don't like the vibe fruity o's
i'm like come on guys fruity hoses spend
the extra dollar get the froot loops in
here fruity o's in a bag was okay i'll
tell you that though i don't know about
that where'd you uh
i like he called you out he's getting
comfortable he called you out of like
that guy's a bozo
[Laughter]
um high school did you go to like one of
those like performing arts schools out
there in queens
i went to saint francis prep nice yeah
and fresh meadows
didn't really like it but i uh i went to
pub school my entire life went to uh
there's a school in astoria uh it's ps2
public school 2. i went there then i
went to louis armstrong middle school
see there you go it's at frank's dean
martin school for yeah that was dancing
it sounds cooler than it was like it was
like you know a regular school there's a
frank sinatra school out there isn't
there isn't there frank simon that's the
one next to the movie theater with the
bedbugs
yeah i went there i majored in hitting
broads
i went a minor in backhands
i studied minding my own [ __ ]
business that's what i did
then there's a laguardia school but i
don't even know that i don't even know
where the laguardia school of performing
that's what it is right next to regis
philbin universe
shout out to regis he's doing a good job
over there derek jeter i'll tell you
that
he just went down recently right a
couple years i got yeah a couple maybe
two years ago the other day i remember
the pain i brought it up the other day
my friend's like he's dead i was like
wait hold on really yeah dude i saw him
live i saw him went down yeah he went
down
he got whacked
you saw him live
now i saw him a few years ago our friend
was on a tv show we went to a taping and
he was the guest and he came out even
this is how much of an old-school pro he
was like just showbiz guy he came out
during the commercial breaks and was
just like doing crowd work with the
audience just making these housewives
these moms from like indianapolis's life
dude they were all blushing and holding
their pearls is he like a little dude he
seems like he's a little guy but dude
dress he was [ __ ] everything was he had
one of those shiny who wants to be a
millionaire suits on they were doing all
right regis was all right i heard he did
fly me to the moon from the casket which
is pretty impressive i believe nothing
on that
nothing on that fair enough we're
playing hardball okay
let's get into it
uh did you go to college
for a sec i went uh
i went to queensborough community
college and i did a semester there ivy
league huh
really hit the books it was my safety
school
i had a scholarship
they gave me a hot dog and then i went
to class
yeah exactly
i did a semester there and then i signed
up for another semester and then i just
didn't go but i was pretending to go
for your mom for
astoria to get to queensborough
community college it's like 15 20
minutes it's in like side so i had to dr
i drove i don't know why i could have
just parked her i knew he could have
parked around the corner nobody would
have known but i drove all the way there
and i would just park outside campus
wait like 40 minutes like okay and go
back home
wasn't she paying for school
yeah well she paid for a semester right
and she was also asking for my grades
but i didn't even know
i would just wasn't really
thinking it out i was just like i don't
really you know care i was a good
student too like in high school i was
always like high 80s 90s or whatever so
i just like wasn't into it at all like i
couldn't get into it so i was like i
don't know and then i was just like i
said i was pretending to go i didn't
tell my mom that i didn't go
because then i dropped out after the
second semester right it already like
went yeah you already wasted whatever
that like you know 1500 bucks whatever
the [ __ ] is oh so she paid for that
semester but you just stopped going yeah
i did the same thing yeah
it's a good strategy you guys should try
it
if you're out there if you want to get
your masters
just sign up don't go as long as you got
the cafeteria card here all right um
what'd you get on your sats
not good were they at a they were out of
whatever 24 or 24 he's a young guy i
hope it's not 24. i thought it was 21.
oh 21 yeah you're right 21. joe how old
are you exactly i'm 30. i just turned
30. yeah i was born in 92. 92. that's
good math
that is good math it's sharp it was on
your wikipedia
i'm impressed that you thought that i
backlog that
yeah yeah you don't know what type of
idiot you're dealing with
i think he's getting an idea
he was trying to get it out he was
trying to add up your youtube
subscribers it took him three days
um
wait where are we sats sats yeah i got a
i got a 1480 on that and then i took it
a second time and did worse oh that's
not good
i also cheated the first time because i
like [ __ ] who cheats on the s.a.t.s i'm
a methodical cheater are you yeah
because i how'd you do it i i you
because they don't sit you next to
people who has the same test as you so
you kind of have to fight it's not the
first to set the first time giving it i
didn't know that i thought everybody
took the same test
well no versions of it yeah and really
it's like they're very similar if not
the same questions just in different
orders so what they'll do is the people
who are here
have different tests but those people
had the same one so i figured that out
i'm like oh it's just this girl has the
same thing and i would only cheat on the
sections where you had to read and then
answer the questions i was like i'm not
reading this yeah so i would just wait
and be like okay cool and then she there
was like a lunch like a little lunch
thing like in the middle of the test and
she broke out and she had three
different salsas and i was like i didn't
do well on this i was like there's no
way this girl knows what the [ __ ] is
going on she's got three different
salsas breaking out dips wait so she
wasn't in on the scam she didn't know
she had no idea i was cheating off of
her oh so i thought you would have found
the smart smart person and got her
involved i also took it at a [ __ ] high
school and the proctor gave me the
answer to a question
on the sats jeez unfortunately it was
like the easiest question on the team
you would have probably got one yeah and
i'm like what am i supposed to thank you
for this [ __ ] two plus two thanks for
the gimme she just walked over and she
was like
really yeah i was like that's damn
probably super illegal lady yeah she put
it on the line for me gave me the answer
and asked for a sick yeah she's like i'm
going out to catch a cig here's the
answer book
[Laughter]
i'll be back i had a teacher tell us if
you ain't cheating you ain't trying and
i still live by that
that's fantastic love that
not a good test taker hmm
what was a vacation like growing up
where'd you guys go we're just summer
we never went on like an actual vacation
um
there was a few weeks like like a
weekend out of the year that we would go
to this house upstate with like a bunch
of other families
cousins relatives are just different
one family was our
actual cousins and the rest became like
our family friends i think it was like
my parents friends when they were
growing up gotcha and then when like
they had kids and then they you know we
would go to this house but that was like
the only vacation there was one other
time
my dad uh did some construction work for
this guy and he got us tickets to disney
world
oh god and i don't know if he actually
did construction for this guy or if
something happened i have no idea but we
did go to disney world and i had a great
time that's awesome how old were you i
think i was like seven damn get let's
talk about helix baby he looks best in a
biz love him not only a spokesman you're
also a client yes sir you're re-upped
after the free one i re-up they sent me
a queen the twilight we took the
two-minute quiz me and my me and the
lady now why didn't you want to go to a
uh to a mattress store and walk around
with some bozo on a saturday listen am i
an [ __ ] standing there talking to
some guy with [ __ ] coffee breath a
short sleeve button-up shirt making me
lay on a bed no offense to them
personally but there's an easy way to do
it easy and
21st century takes two minutes to do the
quiz you you sign on it the matches
whatever's good for you you gotta go
pick it up
you gotta go pick it up the mattress
they send it right to your doors
look at that best night's sleep i ever
had
it's easy peasy uh 10-year warranty and
if you get it you can try it risk-free
for a hundred nights don't even pick it
up if you don't love it but i'm telling
you you will helix even has financing
options and flexible payment plans so
it's a great a great night's sleep is
never that far away
here it is boys and gals get your pens
and pencils write this down helix is
offering up to 200 off mattress order
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com garbage one more time
that's helixsleep.com
garbage do it yeah this podcast is
sponsored by better help online therapy
gang better help want you to remember
that the most important relationship in
your life is with yourself so if you're
not happy or something standing in your
way of happiness better help can help
everybody suffers with uh
with uh mental health issues and all
that kind of stuff better help brings it
right to your home in the privacy of
your own home yes better help is online
therapy that offers videos phone and
even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy it can be matched with
a therapist in another 48 hours give it
a try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and all you garbage listeners get 10 off
their
first month at betterhelp.com
garbage that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash garbage do it yeah yeah
how did you find out that's how you came
across these tickets did you did he come
home like i got good news yeah yeah yeah
i really don't remember him like
announcing it and being like we're going
and i like cried or something like i
don't really remember i do remember
crying a lot when i was there because i
was a little [ __ ]
i needed to be attached to my mom dude
getting paid for construction work in
disney world
i mean that's an expensive price tag
that's what i'm saying it's not like he
gave you a [ __ ] you know i don't know
if it was as expensive as it is now
because now you get because we were a
family of six
and then also 30 grand to take a family
of six to disney world now for like for
for a week easily yeah it really is it's
like it's like i've been recently and
it's like no matter what you try to do
the cheapest thing it's at least three
thousand dollars yeah yeah like at least
and not even like staying at a resort
just no you're staying like off camp
off-site
and they're building [ __ ]
neighborhoods now you know that right
yeah yeah oh yeah this is building yeah
we're taking him that was one of our
patreon goals uh when we hit i forget
what it was like three thousand or
something
we're taking him i'm taking him to
disney world first make it sound like
i'm nine when you say we're taking him
we're taking this idiot well you're not
taking us
or taking car seat yeah never been never
been man never been always jealous my
cousins went [ __ ] all the time we
never went and then my [ __ ] mom goes
with her girlfriends like for a
bachelorette
one of them party goofy
you know my one of my buddies who i do
the basement yard with my friend frank
his dad when he was younger
uh
it was he was it was my friend's
birthday and his dad's like oh you know
happy birthday whatever and then did
whatever and he told him by the way i'm
going to disney world with uh cause his
parents are separated he's like i'm
going to disney world with another
family what like told him that he was
like
cool all right nice yeah happy birthday
to me damn nobody bring it back anything
i will that's cool but you got to give
me the money now so
probably got him a key chain it's nice
and the thing about about your dad's
deal i would have to assume unless the
guy he was doing construction for
worked for disney or was one of the
disney family that those disney tickets
that your family now offers
no
was probably for that guy's family uh
and they had to get construction done
like we're not going to disney world
oh i don't i mean it doesn't matter he
got to meet mickey i never considered
the fact that we destroyed a family
that's like when tony soprano took the
car off that guy
yeah that's half the fun if i was if i
was your dad i would have been telling
you that down there i mean yeah it
doesn't make sense that he would just be
like yeah just give us tickets because
they were physical
like tickets yeah
so uh you know
i don't know why you're megan smith for
the week all right joe
you got to put a wig on all right just
put a wig on it shut up
oh that's beautiful
what's the extended family situation out
there did you have a lot of cousins and
stuff like that or
yeah i have a lot of cousins
not a lot of them live like in the city
we're the only ones that live like in
the five boroughs okay so there's some
that are on long island and there's some
in jersey we have one psychotic part of
our family that lives in maine and ice
just collects a bunch of guns so much so
that the fbi has to go there a couple
times a year really yeah just keep tabs
on them also like out of my entire
family if i had to pick one
man
to not
carry guns it's that guy it would be
that guy well no the guy who has the
guns would be second there is one other
guy that i just
there's one guy who's legally not
allowed to have guns
he's he can't vote or have guns or
anything like that so he's won
but yeah this guy's second um any any
aunts or uncles or cousins that you call
by a name that's not their name like an
aunt cookie and uncle jojo and aunt
toddy
yeah we i i have uh
i have an aunt maureen that i call uncle
moe whoa
but i'm the only one who does that all
right
that's what we're looking for oh yeah
that's the number one answer i don't
need steve harvey to tell me that there
you go
uncle moe that's what i call that's
awesome she doesn't like it no
no not at all as a family grown up in
queens would you guys ever go into
manhattan and if you did was it like a
big deal yeah that's a big thing that's
a good one like we're going to the city
no i mean
that's pretty [ __ ] disgusting when
you say it like yeah we never really we
never really treated it like that like
to be like oh we're going to manhattan
that's like it's the same dumb shorts
like four stops away yeah yeah right
yeah we're and we're taking the train
it's like okay
yeah real treat when did you start
taking the train as a kid
pretty young because i like that about
city i feel like city kids are pretty
cool because they get like multiple
educations they ate at a very cold at a
very young age i was just talking to
this to my friend about this i was like
dude we used to walk to school together
it's maybe like
a half mile or something like that or
maybe a little less than that but like i
was walking to school in like third or
fourth grade yeah in [ __ ] queens yeah
in new york city i'm thinking i'm like
yeah my
ma what the [ __ ] what's going on letting
us just go and like they were pretty
like cool with us
kind of just being out all day like we
weren't in the house at all like she
would be like coming home at 6 30
for uh dinner and then be home at 11. i
remember those when i was younger were
my like that was your guys
11 o'clock at night yeah not in like
third grade like that's not i wasn't
allowed out there boosting
third grade no but that was probably
when i was in like middle school i guess
so like sixth to eighth grade those were
like
yeah you know that's still pretty late
eighth sixth grade out until 11 o'clock
at night i had all your kids grow up
quick yeah
any graffiti when you were a kid you
tagging anybody any place up i i never
really got into that
because
all the kids that did were just sucked
like i was like maybe if there was like
a cold or crude my friends were doing it
i'd be like yeah hell yeah but i like i
don't know we never really got into that
have you ever given yourself a rap name
at any point name at any point did you
try a rap career or think about it oh
absolutely i think you can't grow up in
the city without having that point
i got this 100 i could definitely rap a
little bit can you break dance
absolutely not
i think that's reserved for like
filipino guys and uh just not me have
you ever done the apple watch have you
ever done showtime dancing on the subway
no not at all no dancing of any kind for
money
if you got any more dancing questions
they're all about can you do the waltz
what's your worm situation
is there a meringue for a couple dollars
first job
uh first job
i guess like my first like real job that
stuck was a i worked at a pizzeria
delivering pizzas nice and
actually it was an interesting story of
how i got fired from that job well i was
fired out of necessity because i was par
i had my dad's red van
first of all what kind of van we talking
just a
mother's van yeah i don't know like a
minivan like a minivan with a subway
sandwich stuffed into like the [ __ ]
console of the thing that he would
probably eat you know every three days
or something like jesus but uh he he let
me use his van on days that i worked and
i worked thursday friday and saturday
only three days a week and the first day
on the job
i pulled into the parking lot and
immediately hit a woman's car
salva canada did the same thing but it
was not at home i got a nine nine
accidents i didn't hit it hard and she
lost it and i was like hi and i was like
freaking out already it's my first day
at work of like my first job really and
i hit this lady's car she just let me go
because there was no mark on her car or
anything i was like all right cool and
then uh backs into another car that's
how i'll see you later that's how it
happened and then that's also how it
ended because i was
parked in a uh spot right behind the
pizzeria and my the back of my car was
already in so all i had to do was like
turn in the front and some guy on a
motorcycle
swerved around a car
and hit the back of this [ __ ] van and
it sounded like a thunderbolt jesus and
i just see a body flying through the
window i'm like oh my god i just killed
a person and he did like a front flip
landed on his back and like skid super
far i just put the car in park got out
and i'm like
yo you like are you good like i'm
[ __ ] shaking two people ran off the
sidewalk and they're like we saw
everything don't worry about i was like
thank god but this guy i swear to god
i'm not making this up the guy was
laying on his back with a cigarette like
this
and he's he's smoking the cigarette i
don't i like this guy yeah and shocker
i'm pretty sure the guy was
albanian his people are tough
he was he was like help me up i was like
dude i'm not helping you up you could be
very hurt and your spine could be in
half so i'm not going to do that who
moved them
and he's like you don't want to help me
up because you know you did something
wrong and then at that point i was
pissed off i was like first of all yeah
you hit me my blinker was on i was like
i wasn't even [ __ ] moving you drove
into me the guy was like definitely
drunk
and he ended up suing me which was fine
really yeah but
it was one of those things that like i
don't know if this is still true but at
the time apparently
a lot of people would stage accidents
sure sure if you sued the companies
would just settle and you would get a
you know just this amount and like no
one would really be hurt by that as far
as like like my insurance never went up
but he got like 13 grand or something
for being drunk oh smoking a cigarette
and hitting me that's wild which he
probably deserved for holding on to his
cigarette the whole through that old
[ __ ] thing which is amazing he's
doing a barrel yeah
he's in the end just like
god damn so you're a scumbag but we give
you an a for effort we'll give you 13
grand yeah and then my boss came out and
he's like we probably should not be
involved in this you're done i was like
yeah really yeah that seems like a you
problem joe yeah this isn't mario's
pizzerias it's like whoa
delivering food i was like
it's like no one i guess i guess no one
i never even met this kid
holy [ __ ] you ever been in a parade in
the parade
like
on a float
no i don't i'd have never even like seen
a parade really i don't think i've ever
seen well the only parade i've ever seen
was when the giants won the super bowl
that's the one i went to and that's the
only thing they didn't let me on the bus
yeah no that would have been nice yo
that's the most new york answer we have
ever gone i know
i figured out there in queens they
probably had them all the time small
they had like little fairs and [ __ ] like
at the italian fair were you're going to
get zeppeli's of course a couple of rats
and [ __ ] that's my next question you
ever work at a street fair i never
worked at a street fair but uh we would
go to them every single year and they
were not safe no no seeing a lot of [ __ ]
go down on ditmar's is nice
yeah but that's the one of course
[ __ ] what happened of course i saw a guy
i don't know what happened but it's like
it's a fair we're playing games to win
goldfish like who's taking this
seriously yeah and a guy pulled a
screwdriver on one of the carnies and
they were like i guess a brotherhood
yeah that i don't know probably the
carney's rolled deep oh they roll thick
dude
the real thing they beat the [ __ ] out of
this guy
they beat the [ __ ] out of him and just
like bringing a screwdriver to a corny
fight
you lose why do you have a [ __ ]
screwdriver but they're like women
holding their daughter's hands and this
guy's just getting the [ __ ] kicked out
of him by like five people and i just
remember him sitting up like the
undertaker and then everyone's like oh
yeah and then some guy comes just kicks
him in the face yeah as hard as he could
and i was like i'm going to [ __ ] home
yeah i'm getting deep-fried oreos and
taking my ass out
they turned that guy into a game kids
are taking turns yeah just keep kicking
them
10 bucks a kick you want a teddy bear
kick the [ __ ] out of this guy start
shooting with paintball guys this is
[ __ ]
hmm you own a drone
i do own a drone where do you live now
do you i live in astoria i moved back i
was in long island city for two and a
half years or something like that then i
move back you got your own place you you
live with your mom no i i got my own
place okay you rent or you own it i rent
okay
prices on a piece of property that's
almost oh i do i do own though too
really i don't know it's my mom's house
i bought my mom's house
that's pretty pretty queen
[ __ ] small town kid made good i still
charge her rent but you know i own it
outright she does pay rent and by the
way biz you're late
couple months late waiting for that
i got good news and bad news i just
bought you a house bad news is the
rent's going up 20
you thought you had money problems
before
buckle up and no pets allow that's
awesome
she's gonna get rid of her dog
sprinkles has got to go i'm sorry i'm
sorry i don't make the rules
that's sweet though man that's awesome
you bought you bought your child at home
look at that yeah it's good stuff
have you ever worn a hemp or puka shell
necklace
90s they got your 90s kid they got
pretty big in the 90s i feel like my
answer is yes i never i feel like i was
maybe just like two or three years too
young yeah because
definitely like my older brother
definitely had some shell necklace but i
can tell you this i do remember
being like [ __ ] i need one so bad yeah
yeah also i went through this phase
where i like desperately wanted dog tags
like that was so funny i had dog time
everyone had [ __ ] tried
on the wildwood boardwalk i was like oh
i'm getting [ __ ] dog tags dude like
i might bring dog tags back i gotta be
honest you can't that's stolen valor no
yeah you gotta be a little kid maybe is
is dog tags valor no i think so i think
if you wear dog tags no but i'm not
representing uh you can wear camouflage
and not represent that you're in the
military stolen valor is representing
i'm in the military fair enough mine's
gonna say army of garbage so i
technically am in the military that's
not a [ __ ] bad idea we get dog tags
army and garbage there we go you were
just claiming i was stealing velvet now
you can wet your beak on it you're all
about
it
money talks baby
i'll play ball i'll sell stolen valor
for short i was i'm not gonna wear i'm
not gonna wear it you're gonna sell it
for money yeah what was your cartoons
growing up as a kid what did you like
what'd you get into uh wow that's a dog
question
i was like okay on doug i like tom and
jerry nice classic old school uh
what else i there was a spongebob face
pretty late
yeah late in life yeah like i i was like
probably too old to be watching
spongebob
this is good this is good stuff
uh
let me tell you something spongebob
ain't bad i'm thinking that right now it
still holds up pretty good pretty good
uh hey arnold was big too okay
is that you too he's a little younger
than me why what was what's your answer
i was a i was born in 86 so yeah hey
honor was just like i was like two i was
a little too old for it yeah there's a
lot of stuff that like even kids that
are a year younger than me
like icarly or all these things like
i've never even seen really yeah i've
never i've never seen an episode or i
don't know anyone's name i don't know
anything i was watching icarly in my 30s
i thought
i thought it was that good i don't even
know who's the star of that what do you
mean i do jerry train that show was
hysterical plus i always wanted to live
like in my fantasy i always wanted to
live on one of those sets like a
nickelodeon show or like one of those
disney shows well they had giant open
living rooms yeah
fantastic yeah hey arnold's room i was
like bro
fold-out couch
go hang out on the roof through the
[ __ ] skylight i was like damn this is
all right
like that
is your bed currently in the corner of
your room
and do you have a bed frame around it i
do have a bed frame and it's not in the
corner okay it's actually
in the center
side definitely grew up with my bed in
the corner of the room and i had it was
like a right next to the radiator
radiator whatever the [ __ ] radiator
that's a piece that's trashy yeah i say
radiator over by the radiator you're
ready turn a radiator on my dad got me
on that and by the way no one because
that's not really a word you say that
often and i was like
28 and i said radiator and someone was
like what and that's when i found out
i feel like it's a tomato tomato type
thing you can say radiator i think it's
a garbage not garbage thing really it's
like it radiates heat
so it's a radiation that's like the
nickname radiation the nickname for
someone's jeep dude the red ring
the radiator well listen some guys say
we're having parties
but i i i was my bed was like right in
the corner it was right right next to it
and there was like a little
hole right here which god knows what the
[ __ ] sure sure blows food
how do you pronounce the city in
michigan that starts with a d detroit
okay not detroit detroit who says
detroit i also say detroit
which will be coming there next week guy
it's funny because there was a kid in my
high school who used to say uh
uh instead of blockbuster he would say
blockbuster
i was like how are you saying that right
and wrong at the same [ __ ] time dude
i'm going to blockbuster
and i was like i'm going to [ __ ] hit
that's wild blockbuster blockbuster
that would drive me crazy
butcherbox put your box butcherbox i'm
talking steaks i'm talking chops i'm
talking salmon from the river and is
this low quality stuff made up
mid-quality stuff what are we talking
about come here let me smack you around
what are you talking about it's all
sourced from the source it's the good
stuff so it's from the source high
quality [ __ ] [ __ ]
sustainable there you go yeah it's the
real deal to answer your question uh-huh
thank you for answering my nice rigatoni
with that ground beef there they're
throwing out the doors out there they
can't get rid of that crazy every month
butcher box ships a curated section of
high quality meat right to your home
free shipping top four
for the continental united states please
stop interrupting me no antibiotics are
added hormones each box contains eight
to 14 pounds of meat depending on the
box you choose now if i want to add my
own hormones and antibiotics is that
okay aftermarket add-ons you can do that
in your own house but if you want them
they they ain't got them i like a little
i like a little tea in my uh and my
ground beef a little testosterone okay
up a little bit uh this is your chance
to never have to shop for ground beef
again this is the most this is crazy
this is the most bonkers and i am not
lying when i say the ground beef that
they send you is absolutely fantastic
that's right butcher box is giving new
members free ground beef for life the
most insane sentence i've ever read
that's one less thing you got to worry
about plus you get a 10 off coupon on
top of all that goddamn ground beef
sign up at butcherbox.com ayg get two
pounds of ground beef free in every
order for the life of your membership
plus a ten dollar off coupon log on to
butcherbox.com she wants you to claim
this deal do it do it bespoke post baby
b
bespoke post box awesome box of awesome
box cool guy stuff it's cool guys [ __ ]
you didn't know you need until you see
it and you go god damn i love this stuff
and you know what it's springtime i bet
you it's even cooler cool guys yeah the
revamping you can revamp any category
you got outdoor stuff cooking stuff but
there's numbing stuff bar stuff cool
clothes get a sweet pocket knife
hammocks the whole nine yards we got all
this stuff they sent it to us fantastic
it's fantastic to get started just take
the quiz at box of awesome.com they want
to know what you like your answers are
going to help them pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued at around
70 bucks but it don't cost that you pay
a fraction of the price what do you pay
go ahead uh
i don't know it's not in the copy plus
with that
awesome you're supporting small business
90 that's the cool part 90 of everything
that comes from box of awesome is from a
small up-and-coming brand it's free to
sign up
you can skip a month or cancel at any
time so it's easy peasy get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome.com enter the code
garbage at checkout that's box of
austin.com code garbage for 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com go garbage
do it i'm back to that show wait back to
the show all right
i need your number one option from from
what i'm about to have to ask you here
oh boy uh ice cream cones traditional
cone waffle cone the sugar cone
or the pretzel cone which i know is a
little bit of a unicorn yeah i don't i
don't know that i've ever had pretzel
corn is very philadelphia okay i don't
think i've ever had that than regular
waffle or sugar well what's regular i
thought sugar was regular
isn't it i like the way you think
no sugar
i was like stumped got him regular is
the little the little like plasticky
looking ones that has the little what's
the sugar cone the sugar cone is darker
yeah and sweeter
so probably the sugar color i [ __ ]
okay i hate waffle cones
if it cuts get this guy out of my face
because it's messy dude you bite into it
the whole thing it's a wrap so you're
telling me there's a difference between
that's the classic that's classic and
that's your pink cone it's called that's
your shirt
[Music]
yeah i like those cons they're good
those cake cones they're not bad waffle
cones taste the best they're just not i
just can't use it yeah unless it's in a
cup if it comes in a cup with the waffle
cone i'll do that that's cool
that's kind of a cop-out answer were you
a were you a uh mr softy guy growing up
big time yeah we used to i used to had a
tab one time my dad one time whooped my
ass because he found out i had a six
dollar tab
yeah that tab
cause he would stop by the park he we
used to call him babalou honestly
looking back you're [ __ ] lucky dude
looking back
a little too close of a relationship
with mr [ __ ]
we should get into the truck and drive
us around and [ __ ] i'm like yeah we're
[ __ ] licking a [ __ ] twitty bird
pop or whatever oh man i never got
touched that on record never touched me
ever the 90s were at a different time
some greek guy we used to call him
babalu and then he would call us babalu
so i don't really know his name
apparently i'm also babalu apparently
everyone's [ __ ] bobble into this guy
i don't know what's going on with him
but he i blockbuster if we if i didn't
have money if i didn't have money i
would just go up to him and be like bro
can i just pay you tomorrow
uh a child by the way being like i'll
just pay you tomorrow can i just you
know whatever and he'd be like yeah sure
and then i'd you know you're out there
dragging my name through the mud on the
streets literally i can't get a cone in
any of the five boroughs now yeah you
ruined me my my dad knew [ __ ]
everyone he's like i go say hi to my
friend we're stopping at like a sandwich
cart
[Laughter]
[Music]
he knew everybody but the the mr softy
guy he found out that i had a six dollar
tab with him and he like lost his mind
he's like you're gonna give him 20 bucks
and then you're gonna work for me for
whatever because that was another thing
my dad used to just like be like
tomorrow we're going to [ __ ] uh
patties and you're gonna do we're gonna
grout the kitchen i'm like yeah
that happened with me a lot i'm nine dad
i don't know what you're saying
what was your what was your move at the
mr softy what'd you get twist sprinkles
i i liked the uh the rainbow sprinkles
sometimes i would do the cherry dip
sometimes i would do that sometimes i
would just get one of those shakes but
then all of a sudden like inflation
they're like 20 bucks yeah the shakes
were crazy chill bro yeah [ __ ] i have
three dollars these things are eight
bucks now yeah the [ __ ] i'm already into
you for 20.
plus i gotta go dude my [ __ ] dad
i gotta go do the grout job now
gotta work this off but yeah i would
probably do
i would you know what i never did
the double cone i felt like it was too
much yeah it's like a double cone it's
like it's like one it's a cake oh yeah
and it's connected yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's right it's real fat some
people would get like a bike handlebars
vanilla and chocolate and do like
chocolate sprinkles on a chocolate and
then uh rainbow sprinkles on vanilla i
was like this is like yeah that's a lot
man it's a lot sensory overload i can't
handle that uh any you have a pool
growing up
we did have really we had a dude i mean
if you want to call it that but we had a
a tiny pool because we we didn't have
like a backyard like there was a it was
a driveway that had this little like
dirt patch next to it
and we were able to put a pool that was
i think it was 10 feet round
like back there and we had that for a
little bit
uh and my dad that was like where a car
should have been
or yeah yeah so like we just put we just
put it back there we're like one of
three people in the neighborhood that
had a pool it wasn't very glamorous at
all like if i was fully stretched out
like this i'm touching none of us
thought it was glamorous
[Laughter]
i didn't think it was the playboy
he's like just
i know it sounds all hoity-toity but it
really wasn't so what yeah he led with
10 foot rounds
it's not all it's cracked up i was
picturing a swim-up bar to be honest
it's a shitty pool pretty sick hot tub
though
my dad used to fill it up with because
he he like took uh
a fire hose from the from the firehouse
and hooked it up to the sink hook it up
to the [ __ ] hydrant and we would open
the hydrant and run this thing build it
ahead of a second yeah open it close it
yeah
he's like it's just me yeah
it would be like three kids on the
sidewalk and we all be yelling at each
other all right turn it off turn it off
turn it off and then we you know that's
how we filled it up oh man and then also
rust water that water's cold [ __ ] also
it gets really [ __ ] dirty yeah when
you open it up for the first time the
water's just green yeah and i remember
my my father was trying to
siphon some of the water out so he's
like i know
what and this guy not a strong stomach
at all but he had the hose in there and
he was trying to
suck the water to get it to just start
yeah just goes right
i mean you can guess what happens next
some of this green
i wouldn't
put like a piece of garbage into this
pool it was so disgusting right into
this guy's mouth this guy's mouth
don't even notice [ __ ] guys
not my [ __ ] dad
uh anymore
get it any uh yeah he was thrown up all
over the [ __ ] jesus was there any years
where you didn't open it
that's always a tough look uh i think
it's a stretch right
did you empty it at after the every
summer no we just left it like that but
then and then you can just like shock it
you put like this crazy chocolates in it
whatever yeah so we used to do that but
then after at a certain point we just
like never really went in so we were
like we're taking this thing down yeah
hmm
man this gets trashed
just demoed it
wear crocs
i don't actually i may i may i may do
you own a suit do i own a suit yeah i do
how many
like two okay and they're new okay like
i just got them yeah because i had a
i had a wedding to go to last year
borrowed it for one of my friends we're
not the same size you borrowed a suit
from your friends last year last year
you're making cash what you're
successful you're borrowing suits but
i'm not but i just like it also it's not
like a belt i'm also lazy that guy it is
well not really i mean
you forget there's a lot of friends i
have that are like bought this at men's
warehouse perfect size
no one's getting [ __ ] tailored so i was
like all right it fits all right off the
rack
who's got court tomorrow huh yeah
exactly so i but i just got two suits so
designer
no they were from suit supply
oh i know that place i got a suit that's
a nice place yeah i got a green suit and
a then a navy blue suit that's good
green suits nice this is a dark green
very i know how's the credit score
credit score's good credit score is good
you got a couple of cards i do have a
couple cards mx i do not have an amex
whoa really this guy's
borrowing suits
these numbers aren't adding up i'm
trying
i got three million subscribers here
what's going on
holy [ __ ] capital one card
bank of america and merrill lynch
that's an investment account
it's a business account guys there we go
merrill lynch all right those guys like
[ __ ] rope-a-doped me we're sitting
here calling you doofus yeah i think he
had a merrill lynch you stepped over
american express excuse me right to
merrill lynch that's pretty good that's
not bad what'd you have for breakfast
this morning
do you have any left
uh i don't think i had breakfast really
yeah no i i skip it pretty often to be
intermittent fasting you should try it i
don't really try to you know do it on
purpose but it just happens but if i do
have breakfast i usually try to do
something like
just healthy i don't because like
big lactose intolerant really if i get
near milk it's a wrap but like i can
have like pizza and be like fine but
just milk
proper just milk yeah yeah and i also
like so i i use almond milk for like a
substitute or whatever for like
smoothies or something but he's doing
smoothies that's pretty good even that i
feel like my body knows that honestly
it's it's fantastic it's don't even make
it look like milk yeah it's like just
[ __ ] put this thing in a brown bag
and maybe i'll be okay
but i don't know what it is but you know
so i'll usually do like a smoothie or
i'll do like
[ __ ] oatmeal or something but that's
not i don't i don't really have
breakfast often okay okay picky eater
would you say not at all have you ever
microwaved bacon
i'm sure i have if it gets cold what are
you supposed to do true i'll give you
that i never waved it from the wrong
yeah no i've never that's what we're
talking about yeah no no you either bake
that [ __ ] or you pan it yeah fry it
patty foley microwaves it i'm telling
you it's [ __ ] fantastic
it's trash it's delicious no
um i'm not against the microwave bacon
oh my gosh it shouldn't be don't do it
do you have don't even go down that line
that's a dirty microwave though by the
way oh yeah it's spit clean
i blew up my microwave the other day oh
this is like a month ago i still don't
have a mic would you put metal in there
i put an emperor mug oh what do you know
what an ember mug is no that sounds
fancy it's it is the metal mugs but it's
like uh i i got it as a gift but it's
it's it's so [ __ ] dumb what's it
called it goes that sponsor by the way
but it's like
it's called an ember mug so like it has
like a this thing on the bottom of it
and you hook it up to your phone and it
can keep whatever's in there warm what
yeah i never understood that though
yeah one of these things yeah it's so
unnecessary i don't get that because
people are like hey this call this mug
can keep a cup of coffee
hot for 12 hours i like [ __ ] 12 hours
to finish a cup of coffee two three
minutes maybe yeah i want my cocoa
getting cold
well put it back in the [ __ ]
microwave like i don't know so is that
what you did you put it in the microwave
and it actually because it looks exactly
like another mug that i have and i put
it in there and then i went to take a
piss and when i came back there was a
fireball in my [ __ ] microwave and i
was like
okay
so then
microwaves my father's a [ __ ] fireman
so i knew keep it in there let it
suffocate the fire and then as soon as
it went out i opened it and it caught
fire
shut it again caught a backdraft on a
microwave fire and then i used a beanie
to like grab it and throw it onto the
balcony and i was like
battery fires are so dangerous yeah yeah
it [ __ ] exploded and then i and then
after the dust settled because there was
little dust in the air i opened it and
it just looks like a grenade went off
like it's completely like painted black
and like there's like soot there goes
the security deposit yeah that's a put a
little bacon in there actually you know
you guys would love the landlord to my
building because he literally looks and
talks like tony soprano
and the next morning i saw him and i was
trying to like ease him into the fact
that i almost blew up my [ __ ]
apartment and i was like hey man like
i uh had a problem last night he's like
what's going on i was like
bothering you i was like yeah so what's
his name i was like it's ember mug but
i was like i put something in the
microwave and it exploded and it caught
fire and now the thing is all [ __ ] up
and he was just like we'll get you no
one is don't worry about it and then he
sent me an email and he was like
i'm going to send pc richards to your
apartment
just tell them that you you'll pc
richard owes me he goes tell them you
have no idea what happened i was like
i was like
no problem that's great that's awesome
if you see richard's you didn't see
nothing all right that's under warranty
that he's getting a free 100 he was like
tommy have no idea what happened they
haven't showed up and i haven't
microwaved anything since damn that's
awesome how do you not know what
happened i wasn't here i don't know it
exploded i don't know that's [ __ ]
great
how do you like your eggs
scrambled okay just a classic old school
are you an egg benedict guy
um
i
it's not like my first choice but i like
it okay i'll do a benny all right i'll
do a benny every once in a while add a
brunch or something okay do you
currently have a pepper grinder or
pepper shaker
i have a shaker okay just like the old
school yeah just a little bit of this
good question kippy that is a good
question really classy the people have
the electronic ones that's whoa i didn't
even know that was a thing and there's a
light on it too what's your salt
situation you himalayan uh pink sea salt
what are we doing
the sea the seed the seeds okay
okay you cook at the house i not as
often as i should no the microwave is
broken
how the [ __ ] am i gonna make bait how do
what am i how am i supposed to make hot
pockets now
shout out do you have a go-to frozen
pizza
you're not gonna like that answer oh
because well i just recently started
having these
ah
it used to be elios
that was that was the one but now i i
have these [ __ ] uh
cauliflower powers
i didn't know how that was gonna go over
no lava
not that bad california pizza kitchen is
that what you're doing no no colleen oh
you're doing oh you're looking at that
okay yeah they're they're pretty good
they're pretty good they're not the same
but they are the pepperoni is all right
it's good enough to trick me into
thinking it is i'm doing a nice thing it
is i walk out and go that kind of that
that fulfilled the pizza itch and
fulfilled uh me eating healthy itch amy
puts out a pretty decent one too also
elio's
one elios
who is this filling up i i literally eat
that and my body feels nothing i feel
like i didn't eat anything i'm like i
need to eat at least two of these you're
talking about the the square the whole
strip not because initially piece
yeah this one oh now who's eating like
one i know that's great that's psychotic
how crazy is that break in there it's
like flush that's like wiping with one
[ __ ]
nuts
but that is the serving size apparently
is one third of that slice oh that's
psychotic i could eat two like three of
those were like easy oh they're a
[ __ ] best man yeah shout out to
helios hmm no one of these known
digiornos love additional fake digiorno
guy big huge digiorno
powers i i haven't had a digiorno in
years they're good they're self-rising
self-rising
[Laughter]
when they get a stuffed one
whoever invented that oh god good stuff
oh my god like pizza hut when they come
out they act up some crazy [ __ ] yeah
they got real they got real desperate
yeah in the late 90s early tooth like
now the pizza crust it breaks off into
like garlic knots it's like what are we
doing give me the nuts give it a pizza
now they have that [ __ ] tool chest
that they give you that has like
breadsticks pizza [ __ ] dessert in it
and like a little thing that pops up and
it's like fries i'm like what the [ __ ]
is it who's buying this i don't know
how much there's a there's a guy named
rob mason who
according to google google claims to
have invented the stuffed crust pizza
classic rob mason that's awesome
claiming he made it flames it's so funny
yeah i thought of that
those [ __ ] i called them and said
i got an idea for a new pizza cross and
they said it was in development is this
some guy who never even tried he goes no
i thought that yeah and now he's just
making a blog about it
uh
do you or anyone in your family call the
bathroom the john the commode or the lou
the lou is insane that's crazy right uh
yeah what is britain or hit the head hit
the note
uh
i think
when you said john it kind of reminded
me that my father refers to my mother as
john what yeah yeah yeah my friends are
very confused by that but we were like
we just called her johnny's gay yeah
because he would sit down and do the
crossword puzzle and he would and he'd
be like john what's a three-letter word
for you know whatever and my friends are
there and they're like who the [ __ ] is
john i don't have a john in my family i
don't even have a john in my extended
family so i don't even know but he would
call her john and she would answer and
they'd be like what and i'm like i don't
know he wishes she was it must be some
kind of old-school thing because i had
an uncle
my my aunt ray kathryn my uncle my uncle
red my uncle red called my aunt mary
katherine billy
was her nickname was billy billy billy
yeah get in here my yeah my mom's name
is elizabeth he calls her john that's
weird yeah that's like a
separate size that's right but i think
everyone just called it the bathroom i
think my dad may have called it the john
or something yeah
i don't know you brush your teeth in the
shower
no you pee in the shower big time i'll
save a pee for the shower yeah what are
we doing here i love peeing in the
shower that's good one of the greatest i
actually have to drain on my shower
because the other day i was like i can't
piss in this oh it's like all in your
that's a little crazy but you know
i never heard of that drano in the
shower has that the drink clogs up you
gotta talk to gandolfini downstairs
[Laughter]
who's bothering you i'm like i know a
hair or something is in there remember
you don't know what happened here i have
no idea you were you don't [ __ ] tell
anyone you think they bugged your drain
okay
um anybody in your family have a
birthday that falls on a holiday
christmas babies new year's babies
halloween babies
no but there i do have an aunt that
her birthday i think is like two days
after christmas or before christmas or
something so we always celebrate her
birthday okay there yeah okay would you
whether at a christmas gathering would
you be like on christmas would you
celebrate it on christmas day her
birthday yeah yeah yeah would you say
your birthday cake with a birthday cake
and singing yeah that's tough
birthday cake on christmas is bad that's
yeah
yeah you got an ice cream cake it may
be thanksgiving it's one of the big ones
it's one of those but i'm pretty sure
thanksgiving's all right i deserve give
you thanksgiving thank you because
there's pies and everything getting put
out yeah yeah yeah that's tough though
ever ruin a surprise party
have i ruined a surprise party no but i
did ruin thanksgiving once when i was
younger because uh
i
was just
too confident in my strength and thought
that i could bring the turkey to the
table
little boy arms could not handle handled
yeah and it slipped right off but
this will not help my cause at all we
just kind of picked it up and went
you got it with that
dropped it right on the ground and i was
like whoops in the house in the kitchen
in the kitchen yeah yeah i mean yeah at
that point you're not gonna ruin it
completely real you gotta have the you
gotta eat the burger we can't just have
[ __ ] sweet potato pie but here's the
thing this is what really determines
whether you're garbage you're not in
that specific situation yeah you're a
young kid you're trying to be you know a
big boy you want to bring the turkey out
what was the initial reaction from your
mother and father when that turkey hit
the ground was it it's okay we'll take
care of it or was it more of you
my mom never never called me a [ __ ]
thanksgiving you should meet denise
she also rarely said [ __ ] but everything
else she would say and yeah she was
immediately pissed off yeah
[Laughter]
what are you
and i was like i
i think i ran too i was a big runner
when i was younger something would
happen i go i'm out
they would chase us too so that was the
thing too well my dad never chased us
because he would come home late and then
he was a bigger guy so we could hear him
come up the stairs like you better
pretend to be asleep right now yeah he
can't hit a kid i had a good poker face
my brother did not and we got beaten in
tandem so
i was catching beatings that were not
mine
through the fake snoring idiot don't
over sell him he fails at class i'm
getting hit i'm like how am i
you know but that's awesome a valuable
lesson i think
something in there
there is something in there i'm sure i'm
sure child abuse
spent 30 years i haven't figured it out
yet but
i'm sure there's something
do you have name brand luggage
away away sponsor
no no okay no i think i just got it all
right i got that
stuff do you guys have nice luck i don't
have no like good luggage no you don't
seem to be a spender which i like are
you a saver i did you make any stupid
purchase yeah it was there yeah and also
when did you start making money i
probably started early 20s uh 2017
probably
yeah was when i started like okay and
then i moved into an apartment that was
like to
i lived in long island city and i bought
a uh three thousand dollar
arcade machine or something that i like
never used like a pac-man machine or
what was it it had like a bunch of all
of them yeah it had like 60 games on it
so i was pretty psyched on it for a week
yeah and then i was like okay this is
just standing in your house yourself i
when i moved
i um
had i had movers
move it because i was like there's no
way um by the way getting that into my
apartment i totally forgot about this
but i lived in a walk-up and i was on
like the third floor
dude you brought an arcade machine and a
third-story walk-up and i'm an idiot
because they were like do you want white
glove delivery and i was like i got it
yeah it's a [ __ ] 300 pound arcade
it's a fridge it it's probably heavier
than a friend and a guy comes off the
truck
and he's always gotta go if you're in
new york you gotta go white glove bro
this guy
this big
and and then he's like he i remember he
gets off the truck and i go
i get down there and it's seven am too
and i'm hungover and i go [ __ ] and i go
yo if i give you a hundred bucks will
you help me bring it upstairs and he's
like yeah
and he just all he go he goes into the
truck and i'm thinking we get like a
hand car or something he pulls out a
rope
or something ratchet strap and he starts
wrapping it around his wrist and he goes
are you strong
nah man i'm not
he goes you run away you struggle and i
go i think i'm stronger than you and
he's like all right you get in the back
so i'm supporting the weight of this 300
pound thing i almost died and we
couldn't even get it all the way up so i
gave him 50 bucks i got it through the
second floor holy [ __ ] are you kidding
me
i was i was like bro we didn't get it up
there he just quit he was like we can't
no i was like all right well [ __ ] i'm
not [ __ ] giving it to you
but then we had some other movers come
and they and they like did it but then i
ended up giving it away to one of my
mom's neighbors who had a younger kid
that's pretty cool you're a nice kid at
heart i can tell uh we got you got a car
i do what are you zipping around in in a
range rover there
arcade games blowing up microwaves now
we find out where the cash is going it's
the range nice what color black it's
black you gotta go murder now you gotta
go murder it out when it comes to
arrangements
no tense but black i mean the back
windows are like i think sort of tinted
on their own but they're not like black
what are you sitting on a couple of
twenties what are you rolling around
then i don't even know it's better
whatever it comes with i had them
painted black though
what the wheels the the tie uh yeah the
rims oh that's [ __ ] sweet it's like
knight rider i like that
all right so there you go yeah you're
flying first class when you when you
when you zip around not all the time
i've actually never
done it but i just booked you've never
flown first class
not on my oh okay
like i i have like been in first class
before sure i rarely like do that though
but this summer i'm going to greece so i
booked a first class ticket for that
because i was like that is going to suck
yeah that's nice that's the vacation you
deserve it yeah solo uh it was my it's
my buddy's birthday so
the squad's going yeah there you go
that's good now
are you only in first class by yourself
and they're in code or you're all in
first class uh my other buddy he's in
first class as well nice so does
everybody fend for themselves you're
like i'm sitting first [ __ ] bozos
we're the only
ones come up and get a sip of champagne
tell the poor people i said hello they
just have that curtain like you can't
come to the bathroom in here i'm sorry
uh but
yeah no we're we're the only two i think
are on the same flight and everyone else
is just
gotcha you know find your way there i
guess you gotcha that's nice okay
if you go out to dinner with your boys
are you picking up the check is it is it
going a rotation are you guys splitting
the check um
i i i pick up checks but also like if i
go out with my friends mostly we'll like
split one of the things that i do
probably spend a lot of money on is like
restaurants and stuff because i do like
going out tonight that's good
also like fine dining places nice um
split evenly or yeah
no no no i never i never do that like i
never i wanted to like you so bad that
would have broke my heart no if you're
like oh wait i had two sodas and you're
like
they charge you for refills what kind of
joint is this yeah no thankfully i i
don't have friends go out without do
that that's so funny chaz palm and terry
almost gave the exact same answer yeah
two sodas yeah he's like who had the
shrimp yeah oh we don't do that we don't
do that
you telling me this is i said tap you
put still that costs money
um but yeah no i that is horrible and
also like we won't split well like
someone will just be like i'll put it on
my card and then we'll like bend my own
stuff yeah he's good he's a good guy
gentlemen yeah he's all right you can't
put five cards in there
psychotic yeah it's nuts i hate that
what else i got two from the patreon
okay i mean i'm pretty i mean i think we
got him pretty dead to the right so yeah
if i'm being honest with you
the walt disney trip payment the pool
[ __ ] cheating on the sats jesus
forgot about that uncle moe or whatever
her name was
big cigarette smoker by the way if you
couldn't guess yeah
[Laughter]
being into the mr softy guy yeah whoa
being into his uh you know i don't know
about all that but
it was six bucks
i said i was good for it
uh all right this one's from sam skye so
as you know when you join the patreon we
will answer we will ask your garbage
question on line uh or
on air it's just the best way to do it
uh this is from sam have you ever
brought the laptop to the bathroom when
you're taking a a deuce dude
all the time really all of the time is
youtube sensation what do you mean what
he's got his chest
no i i mean i feel like that's you know
yeah i can't gotta do something you get
the phone though a computer that's a lot
well you gotta go in you gotta find
somewhere to put it you gotta take your
pants that's a generational thing he's a
younger guy it's usually like in the
morning because the coffee gets you and
you're already like doing stuff on your
laptop
that i understand at night though let me
ask you guys a question go right ahead
please 3am you got to piss yeah yeah
put the light on it hurt your eyes yeah
i go light off and you guess what but oh
you guess or you don't sit
oh you sit i'm not saying i said i'm
asking you
the seat goes up yeah the rim goes up
yeah and then i try to find i'll pee in
the water first and then go two clicks
to the left to get on the wall
so i'm not so it's not you know loud
yeah exactly i go no lights and i'm like
a nervous rookie cop i'm just
i'm spraying it
the only time that comes to bite me in
the ass is when i wake up and go pee and
then two minutes later my girl wakes up
to go pee and all you hear is jesus
[ __ ] christ she's peeing all over the
floor breaks her back
so i don't i don't do the sit piss at
all but there are times where it's like
well i got a [ __ ] and then you piss and
then you're like i don't have to [ __ ]
yeah oh i've done so i now have sid
pissed
a false alarm you walk out of there like
i feel less than i should right now but
in the middle of the night check my
lipstick now i turn the lights on
and torture myself because there was one
time that i
just went for it like an idiot sure and
it sounded like i was pissing on a drum
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is that and
then i turned the lights on it was
closed yeah pissed all over it and then
i was like oh and then even dumber i'm
just sure you know i'm i'm disheveled in
the middle of the night
so i'm just like you know
in the middle of a pee it's very hard to
hold that i don't really have the
strength in my dick to you know stop a
piss like that no so you have like three
seconds man three mississippi and i so i
open the lid not thinking so all the
piss that was on the lid has just went
into the back of it now you know three
a.m i'm cleaning my own piss off that
wait until the morning yeah that's what
i was gonna ask you do you clean that up
on the spot or do you let that ride i
had i had to i'm big on smell so okay
i'm like if i let this go i'm gonna wake
up in the morning my entire apartment's
gonna smell like piss do you have a
cleaning service that cleans your
apartment or do you do i don't i do it
myself okay dishwasher yes washer and
dryer in the unit
yeah
it's all right doorman big no okay walk
up
no nice that's that would be horrible i
i lived in a walk up
forever until this building you want a
high floor
six
it's a top floor same day a six six walk
up ain't no good anything over four i
did a four four
four's a lot four's like you hit it
you're like is there one more is there
not one more you don't you get lost
i feel like four is too big for like
it's a it's just big enough that people
would be like questioning whether they
even want to come over like we gotta
walk yeah yeah 100 or like if you come
home drunk dude i'm not that like
energetic that i am drunk come home
definitely falling asleep in the uber
because that's something i i shouldn't
be sleeping i should yeah i should be in
the trade right now
you know i'd be overseas right now uh
but i fall asleep shipping in dana yeah
if i was a woman to be over but i i
coming home and then having to walk up
all those flights i'd be like i'm just
gonna sleep in the hallway yeah yeah i'm
not i'm not doing this i sleep on the
landing
i like it hmm only last question i have
is uh any family plans with the phones
are you on your own on doing your own
thing no i'm i'm i have my own okay my
own thing
all right but i've i stayed on that [ __ ]
as long as i could i i don't remember
what i think i was maybe like 26 or 27
when i got off of that 46 currently on
his mom's plan stop it i pay it though i
pay it i pay to play is it a good deal
are you guys like grandfathered into
some crazy sprints oh dude we're taking
these people taking verizon the [ __ ]
town i'll tell you that right now i used
to get in so much trouble on that
because you could see all of like how
many text messages how much minutes all
the phone calls you made it was kind of
ridiculous yeah back in the day it was a
really flawed system and everybody was
getting jammed up with the [ __ ]
nights and weekends i remember it was
five cents a text yeah or you would wait
a day and sprint it was like uh if you
wait till after seven it was free
this is before even there was text plans
it was just five cents per text and we
didn't know so i mean my boys were all
just like sitting around talking [ __ ]
like on each other and other people be
like yeah [ __ ] toby stinks joe's an
idiot and then i'm doing i got that bill
we all got to build like our parents
together in the same like two days and
we were all grounded because we saw we
sent like 5 000 text messages in a month
i've done that and also i've done like
in like eighth grade just like on the
phone with my girlfriend at the time and
then falling asleep
and then just having a [ __ ] nine hour
phone call and my mom's like what the
[ __ ] is this dude i try to call it a
work i can't get a hold of him it's just
like a hundred and twelve dollars like
more and she's like well you're going to
have to find this out you got to regret
it
you got to get the patties yeah the
gutters over there
yeah she needs a roof done so
that's great good stuff joe sanogado
everybody look at him 100 percent queens
garbage
garbage what a good guy man nice kid
yeah but seems like you got you got your
head on straight you're [ __ ] killing
it man congratulations i appreciate it
you guys are killing it as well thank
you buddy i see you guys everywhere all
over the graham
thank you anything you want the folks
out there to know you got coming up
there's a lot coming up that i can't
really talk about yet we need stuff i
like that we got stuff coming up too we
can't talk about
everything we have we can talk about
he's lying
we got nothing cool
come to chicago come down oh this will
be out where we're already second show
out in chicago baby oh yeah not too
shabby but i like that stuff you can't
talk about not yet but we got some cool
stuff coming this year love that
fantastic buddy we love you thank you so
much for coming in appreciate you guys
having me you got anything uh come out
to a road show come out and see us we're
all over the road we're announcing more
dates uh for the
summer so uh get them tikis now also
merch is available the link is in the
description get that uh patreon.com
i think it's like i think we're at a
zillion hours of content on patreon.com
okay you can check that out
appreciate it guys we love you joe thank
you buddy we'll see you next week gang
peace